we've been taking the quotes the Twitter
quotes from Reggie Miller from over the
weekend we talked to Jeff Van Gundy
about it reg tweeted would bet my right
arm if this series was even at 22
draiman wouldn't be suspended for game
five and Jeff Van Gundy last hour said
he agreed with Reggie I wasn't sure what
it meant if you'll suspend somebody for
at 31 instead of 22 and I wanted to be
fair to Reggie Reggie scheduled to join
us tomorrow and he had family time today
but kind enough to join us reg thanks
for joining us what are you saying with
the tweet a bit 31 they'll do it but not
too too in my opinion if the series was
even at 22 I don't think the league
steps in and makes the decision to
suspend one of the Warriors best players
best all-around player and really voice
of that team very much the same way they
did not suspend draymond Green for Game
four vs okc even though the thunder went
on to win that game and go up 3-1 the
league did not want to step in and I
wouldn't say be the reason why but be a
factor in not allowing both teams to be
at full straight when the Warriors are
up 3-1 and you've got three chances to
close out the Cavaliers the blow is a
little bit lessened you're playing at
home you're playing in front of your
crowd where you only lost I believe one
game all during the regular season
there's a lot of things that are factors
in your favor so suspending draymond
Green up 31 somewhat lessens the blow
but again when i say my right arm my
right arm obviously made me a lot of
money that's why i say my right arm
that's how much i believe in that but
why selective punishment it's either
something that needs to be called or not
call
now we're four billion you know where we
stand in the series well let's go back
to the play first of all the officials
missed the obvious non-call on LeBron
James that should have been a foul and
that should have ended everything but as
soon as LeBron stepped over draymond
Green Danny Crawford the official who
was on the play should have blown his
whistle right there again yeah um but
they let it was a very physical game it
was the NBA finals which I was loving me
would he what the officials were letting
them play but things got kind of
escalated I just don't like there's
there's a couple things that that irked
me the 48 hours delay now I understand
that both teams were probably in the air
flying back to the bay area so it's
probably hard to interview guys so maybe
that's why they waited the 48 hours but
it just looks bad because the officials
on the play didn't even go to the replay
so they didn't go to the replay which
they should have if they go to the
replay and call a technical or a
flagrant it makes the job easier for the
league to come down harder but when
nothing is called on the initial play
the initial point nothing was really
called and then the leak comes back 48
hours later and upgrades a technical for
lebron and a flagrant one for draymond
and obviously and people need to
understand i know he's being suspended
because of the point i know he's not
being suspended because of the punch
there's a big difference the reason why
I dream on is being suspended is because
he has accumulated all the points
throughout the playoffs that's why he's
being suspended it's not because of the
punch to the growing area of LeBron
James you agree with Charles Barkley
that what LeBron did does call for
something rehab solutely like I if the
normal reaction for draymond to get up
like that when a guy steps over you you
you're going it you're not gonna let
anyone step over you I don't care who
did it if you're in the schoolyard if
you're playing a
me that you you just don't do that it's
so as well it's almost one of those
unwritten rules now is it right did
LeBron James bait in my opinion draymond
Green absolutely it LeBron knows how
many technical fouls flagrant fouls
points absolutely he baited him draymond
Green has to be smarter let me say that
as well you you got baited and you got
caught so you gotta out do I agree with
the suspension no but the reaction from
draymond Green is absolutely what anyone
would have done LeBron seemed to lobby
for this after the game yes Anna never
became part of the review process until
LeBron James opened his mouth if the Ron
doesn't say anything if he just says
yeah we had words that we kind of got
into it it probably would have stayed at
that but when the Braun said he hit me
below the belt in my growing area and
with the history of draymond Green and
we've seen it and we've done a few of
the games with you know a couple knees
he did the need to Steven Adams and then
he did to kick to steven adams the game
later and looking over them there is a
history there so the league had to react
they didn't react in Game four by
suspending him and with the beam up 31
the Warriors have three chances to close
out the Warriors so it starts tonight in
Game five they don't get it done then it
moves to Game six with draymond Green
back on the floor but draymond Green put
himself in this position because of his
action before I let you go the fact that
you got the Warriors who were basically
calling LeBron a crybaby somebody had a
LeBron emoji crying klay Thompson said I
guess we hurt his feelings I mean it
like that if there's gamesmanship going
on here you know everyone's trying to
get a leg up and LeBron James is one of
the most fierce competitors in this game
and but they don't hear him it doesn't
feel like they like there's respect or
they may be they don't respect him but
they fear him or one of the other cuz
they're quiet amount I think they
respect him they don't fear Him and
there's a huge difference you gotta
respect a guy that's been to six
straight NBA Finals and has won two
championships you absolutely respect the
resume now do you fear him like you
feared Michael Jordan staring you down
and going to get you 35 40 every night
maybe not but the respect is there but
the gamesmanship is going on because
you've got a warrior's team that's fed
up with LeBron saying well how it had my
full complement of players last year and
the Warriors though they're a little
ticked off you know you've been doing
all this talking and you're down 3-1
that's the bottom line here stop crying
play basketball and let the chips fall
where they may that's where the Warriors
thinking is hey go back to family time
Thank You reg thank you for letting me
vent sorry bud Thank You reg that's
Reggie Miller NBA on TNT the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience